The perfect sports car should combine sexy good looks with nimble steering, aggressive
power, and a high-quality cabin.
It will be expensive -- but not so pricy that
it’s out of reach for everyone.
Porsche, Mercedes and Jaguar have three of
the top sports cars on offer today– but
which one is the best for you?
Let’s get the numbers out of the way. All
three cars have impressive stats.
the Porsche’s come is just slightly behind the Benz and
Jag, but each is a thrill to drive in its own way.
This is the 2017 Porsche 911 Carrera Cabriolet
The engine in this is 420 horse power six cylinder boxer engine mounted in the rear. This is Porsche's famous engine.
Its difficult to describe the feeling when you get behind the wheel.
This is where that mystical Porsche X factor comes in.
The rear-wheel drive on 20-inch Carrera S
wheels and Porsche Torque Vectoring grip the
road better than any other model in our group.
The AMG GT S is faster and more fun to drive
than any other Mercedes – it feels like a rocket ship
This car has a lot to offer. It has that amazing V8 engine, it has the horse power, it has the torque.
Of course, if you’re not careful, the rear-wheel-drive
AMG will fishtail forward with a mind of its own.
That said, it’s amazing in a straight line.
This is the two-door coupe Jaguar debuted
in 2015 as a way to get back in the game,
and the company did it with flying colors
The handling is great, I mean this car is so perfectly balanced. Its really a treat to drive,
especially on windy roads.
The torque that you feel when you drive it
is the most impressive of the group.
But it’s not as connected to the road as
the 911, nor as smooth as the AMG.
It is tight when it comes to steering and
braking.
The 911 is imminently recognizable, yet after
all these years it still impresses.
The front end is flirtatious, the rear is
muscley, and the headlights are friendly.
This is Mercedes’ bad-boy halo car, meant
to recall the glorious gullwing SL
that Mercedes made in the 1960s.
The idea is that its sexy allure will attract
young new fans to the brand.
This is the car you want to get to make a really loud statement.
The Jag is all muscles and roar, punched up
at the seams like a football player.
If you like kind of a hunky mass of metal
and gears under your foot, this one is the car for you.
Porsche was the first sporting brand to introduce
the PDK paddle-shift technology –
which is quicker and better for city driving than
the manual.
There is also a back seat in this option,
something the other two don’t have.
Now,  I don't know if you'd put anybody in that back seat except maybe your dog
Or someone you don't like, but it is back there. You can use it in a pinch.
Inside I loved how the Mercedes looks. It has crazy octopus like round dials all the way
Through the center and the dash. And everything felt thick and rich.
There is plenty to see inside the Jaguar.
Lots of loud blue stitching, performance seats,
and even a handle for the front passenger
to hold on to for dear life.
This is the least well-done of our three when
it comes to interior quality and design,
But its still pretty great.
The bottom line; You can’t go wrong with
any of these incredible machines.
But if you want the whole package at the best
value, the 911 is the clear winner.
Sure, it’s not as aggressive-looking as
the AMG, and it has less power than the Jag.
But its incredible connection to the ground,
its cozy perfect German handling, it's superior
suspension, and it's minimal but quality interior
mean the 911 Carrera S Cabriolet
more than stands its ground.